Henry Kissinger is one of the worst
people to ever be a force for good said
Nicholas Thompson editor at New Yorker
Henry Kissinger what a complicated
person he just passed away November 29th
at 100 years old do you know this man
won a Nobel Prize for negotiating the
end of Vietnam who was known as a
Playboy dated Diane Sawyer dated Shirley
mlan he he was on Playboy that he was
quoted saying this is one of the men
that we would like to go on a date with
on top of that he authored dozens of
books he was the first person ever to
serve both as a national security
adviser and Secretary of State aside
from that a couple of the things that he
said which is pretty wild his quotes
power is the ultimate afro DEC he also
said that illegal we do immediately the
unconstitutional takes a little longer
he also said a country that demands
moral perfection in its foreign policy
will achieve neither Perfection nor
security and he's pretty much the guy
that led the way to get China into the
trade deal matter of fact he was sitting
with ma sadong while he was negot Nea M
says look Henry we don't really have
anything to offer America but we have a
lot of excess in women here we'll give
you tens of thousands of women and he
really doesn't say anything kind of shs
it off ma comes back he says look like I
I said earlier how about we give you 10
million Chinese woman and he says we're
going to have to study that and get back
to you this is a very unique character
Henry Kissinger we're going to talk
about him
today
if you get value out of this video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into so early
life and immigration Kissinger's family
immigrated to us in 1938 to escape Nazi
persecution of Jews his real name is hin
Alfred Kissinger he changed his name to
Henry he became a naturalized US citizen
in 1943 he served in the US Army during
World War II as a German interpreter
also served in post-war US military
government in in Germany he attended
Harvard he earned his ba in 1950 and a
PhD in 1954 he wrote a 400 page essay
titled the meaning of History
Reflections on Spangler Tony B and Kant
it was so long that Harvard had to
implement a new W count limit in his
response his academic career he joined
the Harvard faculty in 1954 became a
professor of government in 1962 an
associate director of Department of
government and Center for international
Affairs in 1957 he went on to direct
Harvard's defense studies program from
59 to 69 then he served as a consultant
on security matters to various US
Agencies including National Security
Council the state department and the
arms control and disarmament agency from
55 to 68 during the administrations of
Eisenhower Kennedy and Johnson in 1957
he wrote a book called nuclear weapons
and foreign policy when he wrote this
book he was only 33 34 years old his
foreign policy when he came down to
nuking everybody when everybody said we
got to retaliate he was not for it
massive retaliation policy opposed
Secretary of State John Foster dulles's
policy of nuclear massive retaliation
advocating instead for flexible response
which meant more of a combination
tactical nuclear weapons conventional
forces and weapons technology
development according to strategy needs
his influence on Kennedy he wrote a book
called the necessity for Choice warned
of a missile gap between the Soviet
Union and the US and influenc the
activities of the Kennedy administration
here's how we increase his influence
politically as ascendants Kissinger's
reputation as political scientist led to
his role as an adviser to New York
governor Republican Presidential
aspirant Nelson Rockefeller heir to
Rockefeller family fortune and moderate
Republican and in 1968 he was appointed
by President Nixon to become his
National Security adviser leading to the
National Security Council Nixon then
elevated Kissinger to Secretary of State
but allowed him to retain his former
role an unprecedented move according to
CNBC the world's richest families in
2023 increased their Network by roughly
$1.5 trillion dollar while many low
middle inome regular people like that
didn't happen to me I'm not experiencing
this and now we're hearing about the
fact that the FED May decrease the rate
six times in 2024 what could that do to
the marketplace does money become cheap
again what do people buy so if you want
to create wealth you almost have to
study what they do what the wealthy many
of them invest their money into is Art
so what Masterworks allows you to do is
let's just say we see an Andy warhall
piece art or you know Picasso Bank SE
it's $2 million a million you can't
afford to buy that whole thing maybe you
want to buy a share of it Masterworks
allows you nearly 900,000 people have
registered to buy a share of that art
piece and many of their investors some
of your viers who use it have got a
return of nearly $45 million buying art
through Masterworks so if you want to
learn more go to Masterworks
artment or click on the link below and
Kissinger maintained in these roles
after the Watergate scandal brought down
Nixon and led to the presidency of
Gerald Ford Kissinger served as head of
National Security Council from 69 to 75
and as secretary of state from September
73 to January 20 of77 there's a lot of
things you can talk about especially
with foreign policy we're going to focus
on four here here one is going to be the
Petro dollar we'll talk about Vietnam
we'll discuss China and maybe the
Chilean where he influenced the election
that that was taking place this guy had
a lot of influence over a lot of things
that happened worldwide I mean some good
some bad some ugly some you may sit
there and say why was he touching Chile
what was he doing with the way he is
negotiating what happened with the
petrol dollar getting off the gold
standard that influenced a lot of the
economy where we are today with all the
printing that we're doing but let's
start off with what he did with China
kinger engineered the opening of
diplomatic relations between us and the
people of Republic of China this
strategic move which began his secret
trip to China in 1971 led to President
Nixon's historic visit in 72 and
dramatically altered the global balance
of power particularly in the relation to
Soviet Union it broke China away from
falling totally under Soviet influence
and gradually open up China's economy to
the World Market this happened at the
same time that the US got off the gold
standard and played a large role in
exporting US inflation by enabling us
companies to use much cheaper labor from
China now some may say that was good for
that time but today we made China a
Powerhouse so some even say Kissinger
was the reason why China became a
Powerhouse okay so the discussion can be
made on what if he didn't do it well
Soviet Union would have been more
powerful communism would have won okay
great but he did do it well China is
still communism and they're winning and
now they're getting bigger and they got
so much control on other Industries some
of that has to do with Kissinger and
Nixon when it comes down to Vietnam War
this guy was a key negotiator in
preventing and finishing up the war
which could have gotten even uglier when
it comes on to Vietnam negotiations
Henry Kissinger was one of the lead
voice for ending the war this is why he
won the Nobel Prize kiss and Jet's
secret negotiations with North
Vietnamese Representatives beginning in
1969 these talks were aimed at finding a
diplomatic solution to end the war Paris
peace Accord his efforts culminated in
Paris Peace Accords in 1973 which
officially ended us involvement in the
Vietnam War courts called for the
withdrawal of US forces the the return
of prisoners of war and a ceasefire in
Vietnam Kissinger was instrumental in
shaping the Vietnamization policy which
involved gradually withdrawing American
troops and transferring combat
responsibility to South Vietnamese
forces this was a very big deal back
then because it was so political
soldiers were coming back that bad
experiences this policy was part of a
broader strategy to disengage the us
from the war while attempting to
maintain a non-communist government in
South Vietnam bombing campaigns during
the negotiations Kissinger supported
escalating bombing campaigns in North
Vietnam especially during controversial
Christmas bombing in December of 72
these actions were aimed at pressuring
North Vietnam to agree to terms
favorable to the US you got to know like
this goes back to the quote where he
says a country that demands moral
perfection in its foreign policy will
achieve neither Perfection nor security
and that's what happens here he approved
of that because he's saying it's not
possible for us to have it if we're not
willing to get a little bit dirty in
1973 there was a controversy with his
Nobel Prize he was awarded the Nobel
Prize jointly with Le Duo the North
Vietnamese negotiator for their efforts
to negotiate peace however the award was
controversial as the ceasefire quickly
collapsed and Le Duo declin the pricee
stating that true peace had not yet been
achieved here's his involvement when it
comes on to the petol Dollar by the 60s
a surplus of US dollar caused by foreign
aid military spending and foreign
investment threatened the system the US
did not have enough goal to cover a
volume of dollar in worldwide
circulation at the rate rate of $35 per
ounce as a result the dollar was
overvalued several measures were
attempted to support the dollar and
sustain Breton Woods foreign investment
disincentives restrictions on foreign
lending efforts to stem the outflow of
the dollar international monetary reform
and cooperation with other countries
nothing worked meanwhile Traders and
foreign exchanges markets believing that
the Dollar's overvaluation would one day
compel the US government to devalue it
proved increasingly inclined to sell
dollars this resulted in priodic runs on
the dollar the Federal Reserve and a
group of economists developed a plan and
Kissinger executed it he made a visit to
meet the king of Saudi Arabia in 1974 as
the biggest oil producer worldwide in
order to convince him to go forward with
the Petr dollar system Saudi Arabia
accepted to denominate its oil in US
Dollars only in convince other OPEC
countries by the samei the oil revenues
will reinvested in us treasuries us will
offer full military security to Saudi
Arabia this is obviously very big
negotiation deal you're convincing
everybody this piece of paper is worth
the same thing as gold standard and the
world bought it they're like okay let's
do it Saudi said yes the world followed
one of the biggest negoti deals that
doesn't get a lot of attention today but
completely change the economical system
till today if there's one of the things
he has a reputation for is interfering
with other countries elections I'm from
Iran he was kind of involved yes no
maybe chillian is a complete different
thing with the Innovation that they went
through here's what he once said he said
I don't see why we need to stand by and
watch a country go communist due to the
irresponsibility of its people the
issues are much too important for the
Chilean voters to be left to decide for
themselves let me read it one more time
the issues are much too important for
the Chilean voters to be left to decide
for themselves Kissinger urged President
Nixon to overthrow the democratically
elected alend government in Chile
because his model effect can be
Insidious according to documents posted
by the National Security archived the
dis involvement including support for
military coup that brought General austo
Pinos to power a move criticized for
disregard for Democratic principles and
human rights this is election
interference but again it goes back to
his quot qu a country that demands moral
perfection in its foreign policy will
achieve neither Perfection or security
and he also said the illegal will do
immediately but the unconstitutional
will take a little longer this one has
to do more about him imposing himself
and saying now communism is the enemy
we're not going to tolerate it whether
it's in America or in another country so
you know many times the question becomes
was this guy hero or a villain I mean
there's an argument for both sides this
the type of guy that you know how you
know a person that they're convinced
they know what's right and they don't
care what what you think this is not
somebody that's asking you what you
think this is a person that knows what
they think and they're sticking to their
guns this could be somebody that you
want on your team not as an opponent or
as an enemy there's many things that he
was able to do that helped America and
hurt a lot of other country some
comparing him to Soros he was not a
money guy I think he died that worth 40
50 million bucks he had some money but
he wasn't able to pull his influence
like he did so look is this guy good guy
or bad guy is he evil or is a hero what
did he do some people think he was evil
because he set in his ways he wanted
power he wanted all of that and he
thought he knew better than you did on
what to do and you know gave the vibe of
if you offended him or God forbid wanted
to cross him probably not the type of
guy you wanted to do it with at the same
time very ambitious similar to like a
Robert Moses what Robert Moses the book
power broker what he did to New York
Kissinger did worldwide Robert was more
of a lowkey guy Kissinger was flambo
Kissinger was out there Kissinger was
putting stuff out there but at the end
of the day he's a guy you want
negotiating on your behalf and he did
some of the biggest deals the has ever
done the last 100 years he's on that
list so having said that if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel if
you've never seen us do a video like
this on George Soros it is a mustat if
you've never seen click here to watch it
take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye